what are the rules of improv
the rules of improv you know yes and
everyone talks about a lot of people
know that but that's really important
you have to agree to someone's idea and
then you have to add something to it
you can't just agree to it or everything
dies so if you say you're a doctor
i go yes and i have a foot infection and
then you would go
yes and here's the medicine and i'd go
yes and so it that is what keeps the
scene forward
as soon as someone says no it ruins it
i'm a doctor no you're not
whoops okay scene's over
um yes and is one uh another one is um
uh don't wimp is what we used to call it
where
you want to have a real emotional
response so if someone says oh this has
been a car accident
your response would be what not oh no
i guess people got hit because you'll
get a laugh in that second
for that but then the scene's over um so
yes and
don't wimp you know always be committed
100 which is
similar to the last rule i mean those
are the ones that i
i follow and then of course when you get
advanced
and you're working with people that have
been doing improv for years you can
break those rules
knowing that they know you're breaking
them so
if i want if i want you to follow me in
a scene we're doing an impression i want
you to follow me
i go don't you follow me which is my cue
to you
to know yeah well he wants me to follow
me because that's so you don't yes and
i don't you know what i'm saying it's
that's advanced level
uh improv stuff but for most people that
are
starting or learning it's yes and
everything so if that's that old adage
in order to break the rules
you have to whatever yeah absolutely and
once you once you know the rules you can
play with them
but it takes a long time to get those
rules down to be able to listen
what's the formula for good comedy i
think the formula for good comedy is a
small room i think people should be
cold and not hot and they should be in
the dark and the audience
and the stage should be lit doing a
comedy show where the audience is
lit is terrible if they're hot it's
terrible
they have to be cold because then it's
builds up tension and then the laugh
makes them
let it out more cold
dark the more compact and
enclosed because the sound bounces off
the walls of the laughter better
um kind of think what else
people you can trust on stage you got to
know that
you're going to do something they're
going to be there for you and not be in
it for themselves like i'm going to get
all the laughs it's like no i have to
know we're a team
so you have all that all those going
that's my favorite way to do comedy you
can still do a good comedy show in a big
theater
or you can still do a good comedy show
people are hot but if
you want all the variables that i like
happening at once is those
and why dark is that because people want
to people are self-conscious
you know if if if i can see the people
around me
it's harder to be vulnerable to laugh
then if it's dark you can't see anyone
often we'll do corporate shows which are
companies will hire comedians to come
out and do shows and
in the corporate environment you have
competitive people and they're all lit
up and they're all at tables and there's
a real challenge of them
not wanting to laugh like because they
think laughing is weakness
and so you know sometimes we'll do these
big
powerful corporations i won't say any
names and
you can see that they want to laugh but
they're if mike sees me laugh he'll
think i'm weak and then i won't get the
promotion
so um there are that's why i think
keep it dark keep them cold don't let
them see each other
we just need to put some dockers on you
and it would have been perfect you know
casual friday and yeah right now that
was that's a great
that's really interesting and it's kind
of like a patient man in a way too yeah
what you're comparing it to
what's your favorite comedy documentary
like the joan rivers
there's all these different comedy
documentaries documentaries about you
know booking
can't oh boy i can't remember what my
favorite carrie no
i mean i know i've seen some i haven't
seen enough um my favorite comedians
are um my trifecta funny is uh
bob newhart uh steve martin and dave
letterman
there are other great ones of course but
those are the three that
i you know the trifecta
right very dry
you know well bob newhart is he's the
best straight man ever and he's the only
straight man i think that got
bigger laughs than the um
comedy people around him right so think
about seinfeld
um he jerry seinfeld's very funny but
kramer and ellen
and um elaine elaine and
jason alexander they would get the
bigger laughs because jerry's kind of
the straight guy and they're like are
the crazy ones around him
every sitcom has the anchor and then the
crazy people around that
but new heart his deadpan regular man
was so
damn funny that he got more laughs as
the straight man
than all the crazy cast around him um
steve martin completely changed stand up
comedy because if
it was very you know lenny bruce suiting
a tie telling or just
or jokes and he came up and just did
absurdism
and it was just crazy and silly and
wacky which is a lot like improv
even though he was a stand-up and then
letterman was just
you know a genius of uh just the
whole ironic movement of just doing
things
poorly on purpose which was just so so
funny
so they all kind of created their own
uh thing right in his top 10 lists
oh yeah we're great but just the way he
would do a segment on the show
like a normal hidden camera segment
would be someone hiding behind
a thing and someone walks up and then
you scare them and that's
his was just it was just a guy
that would walk up somebody go hey do
you have the time
and they go yes he goes look there's a
camera it was like
what just anti-comedy almost it was a
complete
antithesis to the well-produced comedy
bit and he was
doing it and smiling while he did it so
that was great
yeah and taxi too and louie was probably
was he
more of the straight one around all of
the yeah i think so yeah
yeah do you think that there's regional
humor
oh yes there is regional humor
absolutely and it's one of the things we
do when we get to a town
first thing we'll say is what's the uh
what's the part of town where all the
hookers hang out
because there's always a town no yeah in
orlando it was called bithlo
where the rednecks are the hook or where
where's that dumpy part of town
and you just remember that okay and then
just use it in a scene at some point and
they'll cheer
he knows us he knows us it's like no i
just asked somebody what your
what your bad part of town was and just
said it you don't even have to make a
joke you can just say it hey i'm driving
over to bits though what
he knows our town so
or you could it's that that one that's
got the arms folded
you know like was the traffic bag coming
from bithlo you know yeah you can
kind of poke fun and use that too also
it changes over the ages too i mean
um i remember doing a not long ago a
college show with wayne
and you know we were doing our silly
scene and i pulled out a gun
like a character in a scene like i would
have done a million times and the
you know all right buddy give me and the
the gasp from the college kids seeing
a fake i was just doing this and i was
like oh
i was like oh that's so weird i've been
doing this kind of thing for
20 years doing improv when you're a
robber or you know sticking somebody up
and they got they were uncomfortable
with me
doing that with my fingers which was
bizarre
interesting so we have to be more well
you have to know the you know you have
to play to the room
but the room doesn't just mean the room
it means the country or the state or
whatever whatever is going on
um we used to do we used to a game
called moving
people which we stand completely still
we played on whose line a bunch too and
we can't move the audience volunteer has
to move us so we'll
but now because of the you know touching
inappropriate and so now it's like
i don't i don't know if we can play
those games anymore where you touch
people or get
touched just because even though you're
just trying to be funny
all it takes is one person to say i was
uncomfortable and then
you don't get hired anymore so yeah and
now we have like these safe spaces and
everything
you know and that's great and don't get
me wrong but i you know i think back to
you would tune into howard stern because
yeah howard's storm would only give you
yeah i mean you weren't going there to
get a an unfilter you know
censored you went there for a reason
exactly
and uh yeah i guess we it's good to
be inclusive and sure but then at what
point are we being too sensitive and
then it takes away
you know the pendulum always goes a
little too far and then it comes back
and it corrects and it overcorrects and
so it's you know it's a constant
you can look at the history of humankind
and see that's a pattern and it happens
and
you just have to as a comedian you have
to adjust to it but with the regional
is let's say east coast audience going
to want a faster maybe
delivery of something no i don't see
that um
east coast i mean we've we've done shows
all over too we've been
to australia maybe eight to ten times
we've been to
europe we've been canada it's
nothing nothing about the pacing changes
okay
i wasn't sure california you could be
more jeff spicoli like or something
there's different words you can and
can't say that like
saying oh you're such a spaz here means
just nothing right you're as bad as
nothing
and i found out in london wow that's
like saying the r word about some
they're like whoa
you can't say we i'd never heard that
ever
yeah right like knickers i didn't know
that knickers were underwear
in in certain parts of europe yeah and
knickers in the 80s were these like
they don't wear them anymore but they
were you know they were a fad
you know and different things so yeah i
guess you're right but that's
interesting yeah
you